People say when you're pregnant you're eating
for two, but according to the math you're
really only eating for one point one five.
Half of Earth's population takes nutrients
from food and uses them to build a human inside
of their body, but what's the construction
cost?
How many calories does it cost to make a little
bundle of joy?
How many calories it takes for a pregnant
woman to healthily make a baby day-to-day,
is a little nebulous.
It's not just food intake, because existing
muscle, bone and fat tissues will be broken
down for fetal needs too.
But, according to the Journal of Tropical
Pediatrics and the American Pregnancy Association,
the average cost over the entire pregnancy
seems to be about 300 extra kcal, a day -- or
about three tablespoons of peanut butter or
a couple hamburger buns.
If you multiply that out: human gestation
averaging 280 days, 40 weeks, or close to
10 months at 300 calories a day means a pregnant
woman will eat 75,000 calories to CREATE A
HUMAN.
But to put 75,000 calories in perspective
-- it's only a snack or two per day.
U.K. Dietitian Sasha Watkins describes 200
calories as "A small, toasted pita, filled
with a tablespoon of reduced-fat hummus and
grated carrot, followed by three dried apricots…
or a low-fat yogurt with six almonds."
So overall, eating for two, while technically
accurate, doesn't mean doubling food intake,
and instead could mean eating as little as
[[weirded out]] two slices of wholegrain bread
with a tablespoon of cottage cheese??
Brits are weird.
What the body DOES with those calories is
even more weird though.
Caloric increases aren't spread evenly across
the whole pregnancy and do not directly correlate
with actual fetal growth.
They could be used for anything!
Pregnant women will grow 50 percent more blood.
Also, the 75,000 is the TOTAL.
It's not 300 calories from day 1 to day 280…
it ramps up.
At the end of the first trimester the fetus
is only 28 grams, and doesn't require additional
nutrition, but let's run the numbers.
The Journal of Tropical Pediatrics reports
the mean increases for the women they studied
were: 9 calories per day for the first trimester,
8 for the second, with a sharp increase to
216 for the third.
While the American Pregnancy Association says:
women should eat normally in the first trimester,
increase by 340 calories in the second, and
450 in the third.
Then researchers in the UK say normal in the
first, increase by 200 in the second and 300
in the third.
These numbers will change based on BMI, activity
level, metabolism and height!
But honestly, all this variation shows we
still have a lot to learn about pregnancy.
It's not like we can slap a meter on a fetus
and see what they need!
Scientists aren't entirely sure how the body
decides which nutrients go to the fetus and
which go to the mother, but one thing was
clear across all the research I found.
Since growing tissues takes food energy, and
we are what we eat -- it was heavily emphasized
that the diet of a pregnant woman should be
a healthy one.
Craving fatty or "unhealthy" foods is normal,
and shouldn't be ignored or derided!
But, we could all use a reminder to eat healthily.
So, eat those extra 75,000 calories, ladyfriends,
and enjoy building your own human!
Half of those baby humans will eventually
grow up and need to shave one of these lovely
beards.
So we'd like to Thank Harry's for sponsoring
this episode.
I use harrys twice a week to shave my neck
and The blades are sharp, and the aftershave
smells great.
A starter kit includes 3 razors, a handle,
and your choice of shave cream or foaming
shave gel (I like the gel!).
Go to harrys.com now and get your starter
kit for only 15 bucks and with our code
DNews you can get 5 dollars off!